[Music]
[Applause]
did you let her out over she already out
um how did you figure out how to scream
we're gonna have to reinforce your pan
[Music]
my beautiful coats are you hungry ready
for breakfast I know I know I'm gonna
get it just give me two seconds that's a
girl
children yes yes oh my face autumn what
are you doing are you being jealous
don't stand on the Koala Kage's please
autumn would you prefer we open that
pumpkin up a little bit further for you
boys I think this pumpkin needs to be a
little bit bigger whole her entire head
is being swallowed by a pumpkin she
likes it though
[Applause]
don't do it while she's eating it will
smash the other pumpkin how about that
[Music]
I think they like their pumpkins they
eat them up any more where that came
from girls don't be afraid to share only
a few of them go straight or Hey
most of them want those pumpkins
[Music]
oh it's so good you have to taste it too
even though you were just even gonna
prevail okay
[Music]
I just love watching how excited these
goats get every morning they get
multiple pumpkins and if it's been a
rainy day where they've stayed inside
all day they get pumpkins in the evening
Dew and still every time they act so
excited to get another pumpkin
[Music]
Thanks I'm gonna have to stop doing that
running
I think the Bucks ago with me even if I
was walking but who I hurt
I hurts the baby belly I start getting
so big now and the baby's grown so much
that everything and there's just all
shifted around and really uncomfortable
these days even though I'm only half way
through it
who knows the next five months three
months four months how many months
twenty weeks it's running less than 20
weeks left I'm at 21 weeks now so yeah
yeah pregnancy when you're 41 that's
that's exciting
what do you say Rowan yes that's right
for those of you that worked at our live
show we found out that the first two
ultrasounds were tricking us
what do you think of having a baby
brother
still pretty fine yeah that's good
Liam what about gia what do you think of
having a baby brother you really need a
baby boy besides Titus cuz he had a
sweet baby
[Music]
you
yeah